a major fire and a major response in
Germany's second largest city
from Before Dawn firefighters battled
the Flames consuming several warehouses
in an industrial area southeast of
Hamburg Center
German media reported that containers of
hydrogen sulfide were involved a toxic
chemical with an unpleasant odor so fire
Crews and police wore breathing masks
we have been here since four o'clock in
the morning a resident reported the fire
to us initially it burned only a
warehouse but then sped to other
warehouses for various reasons a cloud
of smoke is covering half the city and
we sounded our warning system
a police spokesperson said it isn't
possible yet to assess how dangerous the
situation is people in Hamburg have been
advised by mobile phone alerts to close
their windows turn off ventilation and
air conditioning and avoid the area
the plume of dark smoke also halted
long-distance trains between Hamburg and
other German cities
by midday the fire department had
reduced the Threat Level authorities say
no injuries have been reported yet Rory
challenge Al Jazeera